on peut dire que le port du masque en
effet a été un premier ratage et que
c'est très dommage on peut dire aussi
que du coup comme vous le dites il est
en de lentes d'inertie un des mesures de
santé publique parce que du coup il
fallait mettre le masque partout non le
masque il est fait dans les lieux où
vous avez des risques de transmission et
le risque de transmission se font en
milieu intérieur c'est vraiment en
milieu clos que l'on a à risque de
transmission
alors il y a des gens qui disent vous ne
pouvez pas écarter totalement l'idée que
si vous êtes à 50 centimètres l'un de
l'autre et que vous vous parlait il ya
des postillons qui peuvent sortir de
votre bouche c'est vrai avec les pelles
et bessat encore plus si vous priiez où
vous éternuez encore plus et que c'est
postillons peuvent contaminer par voie
balistique vous vos conjonctive oculaire
vos narines votre bouche
bon il faut être bon viseur c'est pas
évident il faut être vraiment en face de
vous il faut être contaminants ça peut
arriver
c'est vrai c'est une voix c'est
théorique je crois qu'elle n'a jamais
été démontré aujourd'hui encore pour le
corps d'un virus mais si elle arrivait
même à l'extérieur elle pourrait arriver
et donc ce serait la seule raison de
mettre un masque c'est si vous êtes face
à quelqu'un qui vous parle suffisamment
longtemps pas une fois par une
interjection mais il vous parle
suffisamment longtemps de près tellement
près que vous pouvez même pas vous
écartez d'un petit de quelques mois
voilà de daniel d'un mètre dix on est à
ce moment-là peut-être le basque
serait-il utile pour ne pas lui envoyer
vos beaux sillons est utile de sa part
pour ne pas en recevoir
[Musique]